hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty science
here chemistry phd skin care nerd and big fan
of chemicals both natural and synthetic and
today we we need to talk about clean beauty
all right let's do this if you use beauty products
it's impossible to not have heard of clean beauty
it's a revolution you want your products to be
clean you don't want to use dirty products you
want your products to be good for your health
and good for the environment there are beautiful
celebrities telling you about how they detoxed
and cleaned out their beauty routine and how much
better they feel but what if all of this was based
on a lie let's talk about the science or the lack
of science behind clean beauty if you like nerding
out about the science behind beauty products
click the like the subscribe and click the
nerdification bell so you don't miss any videos
clean beauty is one of those concepts that
everyone seems to understand but no one can
really agree on an exact definition like good
music generally the idea is you download a list
of dirty or nasty ingredients from somewhere and
these are supposedly not good for your health
or not good for the environment you check your
products ingredients against this list if it has
any of these ingredients it's dirty if it doesn't
then it's clean it's a pretty straightforward
concept enticingly simple and like a lot of other
enticingly simple concepts it doesn't actually
work if it did i wouldn't be making this video
firstly just to clarify i care about my health
i exercise regularly i eat a balanced diet i
want to use safe and effective products and
i'm not willing to trade my health for nicer
skin i also love the environment i grew up in
a semi-rural part of australia i love bush walks i
try to recycle i try to reduce my carbon footprint
i take public transport i vote for politicians
who want to do something about climate change
i donate every year to environmental causes
what i'm against is feel good actions that
don't actually make us more healthy or potentially
make us less healthy feel good actions that don't
actually help the environment or even make
it worse corporations taking advantage of
consumers' good intentions by marketing their
products based on feel-good actions and myths
so you end up buying products that don't actually
do what they promise and it comes with a big dose
of fear-mongering and guilt-tripping on the side
people who should really know better whether
they're scientists or companies that can afford
to hire scientific advisors spreading myths about
what does and doesn't hurt your health and the
environment if you've spread any of these myths
in the past don't feel too bad we're all human
i've done it before we just have to be open to
new information and try to assess it critically
and try to do better in the future before anyone
calls me a shill this video isn't sponsored there
are a lot of companies in my inbox who want to
pay me to talk about how clean their products are
but i can't because that's completely against how
science and reality work and so with all of that
out of the way let's talk about why clean beauty
is BS in this video i'm going to be focusing on
the health side of clean beauty because that's
what most brands focus on and i don't want this
video to be like an hour long there are massive
issues with the environmental side of clean beauty
as well and i might talk about that in the future
first off ingredients aren't clean or dirty
clean beauty divides ingredients into clean
and dirty or nice and nasty or yay and
icky or non-suspicious and suspicious
or non-toxic and toxic or whatever version
the brand's marketing team wants them to use
but you can't just say that an ingredient is
good or bad without considering how it's used
drinking a glass of water is very different
from inhaling a glass of water and the amount
of ingredient that you use makes a huge difference
as well inhaling some steam is very different from
inhaling a whole river in toxicology the science
of how good and bad substances are for you
there's the concept of a hazard and a risk in
everyday life these two concepts are really
similar but in toxicology they're different and
it's really important a hazard is a potential
source of harm a risk is how likely that harm
will actually happen in a given situation
i asked fred lebreux to explain these concepts
i'm a chemist i'm a phd in medicinal chemistry
and i'm also a toxicologist i have more than
10 years of experience and i've evaluated many
cosmetic products he's the ceo of biorius a
company that specializes in safety assessments
and regulatory compliance for cosmetic products
the risk is a product between exposure and hazard
which means that if there is no exposure even
if the hazard is very high the risk is very low
and when you come to cosmetic products it
just means that a substance by itself is not
good or bad it is more how you are exposed
to this substance that is so critical
to explain i will use a very simple example the
example of a lion so the lion is intrinsically
dangerous it has the potential to be very
hazardous but it doesn't mean automatically
that it is risky if you go to the zoo and you
are behind the bars there is absolutely no risk
the lion is dangerous of course it remains
dangerous but there is no risk because there is
no exposure to this lion if you are in africa in
a safari and you are in front of a lion and there
are no bars between this lion and yourself the
risk is very high because the hazard is the same
but the exposure is not the same anymore the
exposure is much higher so the fundamental problem
with clean beauty is that it makes you rule out
ingredients and products based on the hazards
the potential dangers without considering
your exposure to work out the overall risk
of the situation you're up against it's like
never drinking water because you're scared of
drowning that's why every brand has a different
nasty list because this approach makes no sense
if you only look at hazards then every
single ingredient can be considered hazardous
sometimes clean beauty lists have a token
disclaimer saying you have to also consider where
and how you use a product and how much you're
using so it's not like they haven't heard of the
idea of risk but then they go on to completely
ignore this by telling you it's black or white
clean and dirty if it's on the list it's
out regardless of how much exposure you get
so how do real toxicologists work out how much
of an ingredient is safe to use in cosmetics
once we have qualified this danger we have to
assess the exposure what's the quantity of a given
ingredient what's the quantity that will end up on
the face of a consumer and it's not that easy to
calculate and it's a lot of equations it's a lot
of calculations but we we have to do it and many
parameters are taken into consideration so how
many times a consumer is going to use the product
on average what quantity is going to be used is
it pea sized amount is it is it more is it less
is it a rinse off product is it a leave on product
so all of that is going to have a great impact and
once we have a clear exposure scenario and a
very good idea of how much of an ingredient is
going to end up on the face of a consumer we can
really compare the hazard and the exposure as you
know the risk is an equation it's the product of
hazard and exposure this is how the usage limits
are set how much of an ingredient that formulators
are meant to use in a product these limits are
based on how much of a product you use how many
times you'll use it in a day whether it's rinse
off or leave on and it's added up across all the
different products that you might reasonably use
let's look at one example parabens these are
really useful preservatives that are found on
lots and lots of dirty lists according to these
lists parabens are linked to hormonal or endocrine
disruption they can increase the risk of breast
cancer and they can be irritating to skin all
of this is technically true and it sounds really
scary no one wants cancer or endocrine problems
but if you look closely at the actual evidence
and if you have some idea of how to interpret it
you'll start to see problems so a side note most
of these lists were not put together by scientists
and certainly not toxicologists more often
than not they don't cite any studies to back
up what they're saying first off there are lots
of different parabens and these all have different
hazards and risks but most clean beauty lists
just lump them all together some of them talk
about them separately and then lump them together
anyway now onto their studies when they actually
list them a lot of these studies are done in vitro
on cells or on animals cells and animals behave
very differently from living human skin cells can
die with tap water and dogs can die from chocolate
animal studies also usually involve really
unrealistic situations that have limited relevance
to how we use parabens in everyday life so a lot
of these involved having rats that ate lots and
lots of parabens the human studies also haven't
found a really clear link to health effects even
though parabens have been used for about a hundred
years parabens are mildly estrogenic but compared
to a lot of the other estrogens we encounter in
everyday life like by eating tofu they are really
mild you can also see a pattern in how these
companies treat natural and synthetic chemicals
natural chemicals aren't held up to the same level
of scrutiny as synthetic chemicals even though
there are lots of natural ingredients that are
not good for you this is the appeal to nature bias
which i've talked about in another video on top
of this toxicologists have analyzed all of these
studies before and published their conclusions
and this is how the safe limits of ingredients
and cosmetics are set they regularly re-review
new studies it's not like these clean beauty
organizations are digging up damning new evidence
that no one's ever thought to look at before
now i'm not saying that we won't someday find out
that parabens or whatever other toxic ingredients
are actually bad for our health my point
is that on one side we have scientists with
years and years of specialized knowledge and
experience in this specific area saying that
these levels are safe and on the other side we
have people who don't know the very basics of
toxicology with a very obvious financial interest
saying that we need to avoid them entirely
but why take any risk at all why not take out any
ingredients that could potentially be hazardous
well firstly the risk is usually so small that
there's very little difference and the goal is
not to take any risk so basically we are going
to take the danger we are going to divide it by
the by the exposure and we obtain what we call
a margin of safety and this margin of safety is
at least 100 so the idea is we have to
be absolutely sure that the exposure
to the consumer is much much lower than
the quantity that may lead to an expression
of a danger for the consumer that's a very
quick summary of what we do on a daily basis
we evaluate the danger toxicological endpoint by
toxicological endpoint ingredient per ingredient
then we evaluate the exposure of a given
cosmetic product and we are going via a
complicated equations to mix the hazard and and
the exposure to quantify the risk and this risk
cannot be significant so this is
why we talk about a margin of safety
to be sure that the risk that is taken by the
consumer is very insignificant so it's not like
the amount of parabens or other ingredients that
we use in cosmetics are just below the level where
we see an effect or even half that it's 100 times
less than that less than 100 times less than that
it's already a pretty darn precautionary
approach and it's important to remember that
nothing in life is risk-free a lot of the time
that ingredient has an important function in
the product getting rid of it or using alternative
ingredients isn't necessarily a less risky choice
so option one would be using no preservatives
preservatives are there for a very good reason
every time you open a product it comes into
contact with air which has microbes like bacteria
yeast and mold which can get into the product and
start growing these can reach dangerous levels
even if the product still smells and looks okay if
you then put the contaminated product on your skin
it can cause infections and if it gets near your
eyes you can go blind a lot of these microbes also
produce allergens and irritants that can cause
skin reactions so these are very real health
problems that have actually happened compared to
the largely theoretical risks with preservatives
preservatives have been a bit of a victim
of their own success just like with vaccines
we don't usually think of these risks when we
use cosmetic products because preservatives work
so well they work so well that these problems are
quite rare we take them for granted so unless your
product was manufactured under completely sterile
conditions with completely sterile raw ingredients
and you're only using it in a completely sterile
way like an air free container that doesn't suck
any air back in you'll probably get microbial
overgrowth unless you have a good preservative
system this is especially likely if you're
using natural ingredients that can feed microbes
which is often the case with clean beauty products
so what about option two swapping out parabens for
other preservatives this might seem like an easy
solution but there are problems here as well the
main one is that we don't actually know very much
about the health effects of newer preservatives
parabens have been used for about a hundred years
by billions of people worldwide that's why there
have been lots of studies on them and all of this
data might seem really scary but it's actually
partly because we've been testing them that means
that we also have a pretty good idea of their
health effects which have been minimal on the
other hand neural preservatives haven't been used
for as long and they haven't been through as much
testing and so their health effects are largely
unknown especially their longer term health
effects they could be much worse alternative
preservatives also tend to be more problematic
short term mostly because they're not as effective
as parabens one of the main reasons that parabens
are so popular is that they work really well at
very low concentrations with the less effective
preservatives especially the ones that natural
brands tend to use you can either end up with a
product that is really easy to contaminate and
that leads to all of those issues we talked about
before or you end up with a product that has a lot
more preservative preservatives are often quite
irritating and allergenic and so having more of
it around means that people who wouldn't have had
skin reactions with the lower amounts of parabens
might react to these newer preservatives if you
look at the data on preservatives then you'll
see how good parabens are except of course to
people who are specifically allergic to parabens
these are the incidences of allergy from patch
test studies in the us and europe the actual
incidence of allergy in the general population
will be lower there's also been more recalls of
contaminated products recently and a lot of this
is probably linked to the fact that more and more
brands are avoiding parabens because of the clean
beauty movement so avoiding parabens and switching
to products that don't contain preservatives
or contain less effective preservatives
is a feel-good action that doesn't actually make
us healthier and can in fact make us less healthy
so in summary clean beauty and this idea that
you can divide ingredients into good and bad
is fundamentally flawed from a scientific
perspective it ignores the very basics of
toxicology clean beauty is turning a massive
profit even though it's not making us healthier
and it could potentially be making us less
healthy i do think though that it's important
to recognize that the beauty industry hasn't been
very transparent and this might be why we're so
willing to buy into this incorrect science the
beauty industry hasn't really put in much effort
to communicate the actual science behind beauty
products that's part of the reason i started
my blog back in 2011 i wanted to know answers i
wasn't satisfied with the answers i was getting
and getting to answers that made sense was really
really hard i don't know if it's because companies
thought that consumers weren't interested
in the real science or they didn't think
they could break down these complex concepts
into something that consumers could understand
pseudoscience is generally easier to understand
and easier to sell but it's not the truth and i
find it really disappointing when companies that
have scientists on their staff who know better
decide to cave into pressure and take the easy
route and that was another reason i started my
blog and why i kept going even though i
was losing money for the first six years
i wanted to give the science a fighting chance i
think beauty marketing has been gradually changing
i work with brands from time to time on sponsored
content and over the years i've seen this big
shift from where they wanted me to cut down on the
technical details and just post pretty pictures
to now where they tend to tell me to just go
as deep into the science as i want and i think
the fact that my numbers on my instagram youtube
and blog are growing shows that it's possible to
successfully explain the science accurately and
that people are interested in knowing the whole
messy truth so hopefully that's like a proof of
concept to brands that they can and they should
present the real story instead of giving in to
pseudoscience are you also sick of clean beauty
do you think it's ever going to go away or is it a
movement that's just too big to be stopped do you
think that company's investing in educating their
customers is the way to go i'm a science educator
so i think that transparency in education is the
answer to everything but obviously i'm massively
biased so let me know what you think if you
liked the video click the like and the subscribe
in the interest of making a video that wasn't
like an hour long i couldn't include everything
that fred said but it's really really fascinating
i've uploaded it onto my other channel lab muffin
supplementary info so if you want a more in-depth
understanding of how toxicological assessments
work check that out thank you so much to fred
for taking the time to share his expertise
and also to jen of the eco well for introducing
us she is also a great source for science-based
beauty info especially on the sustainability
and environmental side so check her out as well
i've got more references and info on the caption
especially on the parabens part of the video
so if you have more questions take a look there
follow me on instagram at lab muffin beauty
science and check out my blog for more nerdy
beauty content and i will see you next time